Let's get started.
How is everyone?
[CLASS RESPONDS]
Whoo.
You know why you're so excited?
Because it's a goody bag day.
And I'm not going to deny
you a weekend of goodie bag
action, which is why
you're getting it today.
Even though the topic in the
goody bag is crystallography,
we will not start talking about
crystallography until Monday.
But I didn't want to wait.
I know you didn't
want to wait to have
these models in your
hands because it's
an enhancement of your
weekend activities.
So the goody bag,
again, just sort of
like last time, I'm giving
it out to you today,
but the topic will
start on Monday.
Today, instead,
we're going to talk
about metals and
metallic bonding,
and the properties
of metals that
are related to the kind of
bond that you get in metals.
And you know, we kind
of motivated band theory
of solids with conductivity and
we talked about conductivity.
There is a chart of
conductivity and there's
some elements in there, some
elements and some materials
that are more complicated,
right, like glass
isn't necessarily one
element or silica.
There's diamond, silicon,
germanium, copper.
And we talked about
insulators, semiconductors.
And I've mentioned
metals and that's
what I want to focus on today.
We did this in the context
of the bands, right?
So remember, here you've
got your conduction band,
and here you've got
your valence band,
and the valence band is filled.
And so if there's
a large gap, that's
the gap, if it's large like,
you know, over 3 and 1/2
EV then it's an insulator.
And then the one in between we
talked about a lot on Wednesday
that, you know, if
this is your gap,
and it's say
between 0 to 3.5 EV,
then that's a semiconductor.
And so, you know, that's
what we talked about.
That's in your goody bag.
We talked a lot
about semiconductors.
And then we talked
about how, well,
if you have some kind of band
that is filled in the middle
there.
So it doesn't have to
be filled in the middle.
It can be filled here.
It can be filled up here.
But the point is that
the filling of electrons
does not stop where there is
a forbidden zone of states,
right, where there is no states.
That's what this is.
That's what a gap is.
It's a gap of electron
freedom, right.
Where there's metal,
there is no such thing
because you fill
up to a point where
then right above that
infinitesimally tiny bit
of energy away, there
is a free state right?
There's a free state, so
you're in the middle of a band
and that's a metal.
Well, I mean, this is you know--
so we should say
that the gap here
has to be greater
than zero, here
the gap would be equal to zero.
There is no gap.
You can't define
a gap in a metal.
And we talked about
semi-conductor problems.
I looked up, just for fun,
you know, I mean, why not?
Because what else do
you do late at night?
You look up old exam problems
and you play with them.
And you know, OK, so from
last exam, all right,
so this is for the
semiconductors, we had--
oh, here's a good question.
2.8 centimeters cubed
of pure germanium.
Now I want to highlight
this because there's
one more thing I want to say
about semiconductors before I
move on.
Now, it's doped.
And that's what we
spent a lot of time
talking about on Wednesday.
It's doped with 50
micrograms, OK, of selenium.
That was the problem.
And the first part
of the problem
is, how many carriers
are produced?
And in the same question,
it's like, are they n-type
or are they p-type?
What type of carriers?
Those are things we can
answer based on what
we learned on Wednesday.
And so, you know, oh,
then you have this.
And you say, aha, I know where
to start because everything
starts here, right?
And so pure germanium is doped.
Well, first of all, where am I?
This is my map, right?
Germanium is there.
Now, it's doped with selenium.
Is selenium to the right or
to the left of the period?
It's to the right.
Right?
And so right away you know,
if you put a selenium in there
instead of germanium, so if
you take a germanium atom
and you put a
selenium atom in, it's
going to-- if it's
a doping, it's
going to be in the
bonding network
that germanium was, but
add electrons to it,
if it's to the right.
Right?
And so you know that it's
going to be n-type material.
And if you do the math,
the number of carriers
is equal to 7.6 times 10 to
the 20th per centimeter cubed.
Now, here's something important.
That is twice as
many selenium atoms,
twice as many because it's
two over from germanium.
So it had two extra electrons
for each dopant atom, right?
So the way you solve
these problems,
you figure out how many selenium
atoms are there per centimeter
cubed and how many
electrons for each of those
acted as a free carrier dope.
As a dopant, remember,
dopant simply
give you carriers either
of their-- if it's n-type,
or down here, if it's p-type.
OK?
And this is n-type.
N-type.
OK.
So that's nice-- now the
reason I want to do this is
because, again, it is--
you can never have enough
fun doing problems like this
and looking up old
exams and stuff.
But I also want to go
back to this picture
that I drew for you
on Wednesday, OK?
So this picture was of
the number of carriers,
and remember these are electrons
that carry current, right?
And we sort of drew something
that looked like this.
Now remember, this is, right,
these are thermally activated
and this is thermally activated,
and these are from dopants.
Now, if I put dopants
in, and then I
can get you a constant
number of carriers
because it's just defined
by how much of the impurity
I've mixed in.
How much impurity and I can
control that really carefully,
which means I can control
the number of carriers,
and then eventually,
thermally excited carriers
will just start to dominate.
But this ability to
dope with chemistry
is what enabled the
semiconductor revolution.
Now, you say, OK, what's
going on over here?
What's going on
in this part here?
All right.
Well, you know what's
going on there because we
drew this picture on Wednesday.
Because if I have an
n-type, if that's my VBN
and that's my CBN,
the way this works
is you introduce a donor level.
Right?
That's how doping works, right?
The electrons from selenium
go into here and then
you have enough thermal
energy to get them up to there
and that's where
they're free carriers.
That's where they can
carry electricity.
And so at a certain
temperature below which, right,
at a certain temperature,
if you're lower than that,
well there's not even
enough thermal energy
to get from here to here.
All right.
Not even enough to do that.
So it's got to go
down eventually.
That's what that part is.
And then the one other thing
I want to say about this plot
is that we have names for this.
These are called intrinsic
carriers, intrinsic,
and these are called extrinsic.
Why?
I mean, that kind
of makes sense.
That's actually a pretty
good way to name them.
Because, you know,
intrinsic means
I didn't need to do anything.
It's pure germanium, pure
germanium, intrinsic.
I didn't do anything
to the material.
But it's still--
you can get carriers
from thermal activation
above the gap.
Whereas if it's extrinsic, it
means I did something external.
I added dopants.
Those are extrinsically doped.
So those are just important
distinguishing factors.
Now, I'm going to come
back to this plot later.
I want to talk about metals.
Metals are all
the way over here.
Those are semiconductors
and doping them
or thermal activation
gets me carriers,
which gets me this
connectivity range,
but metals are much,
much, much higher.
Metals are much,
Why?
What is going on in
metals that's so special?
OK.
Well, the way we understand
everything is from the bonds.
So what is happening in a metal?
There's aluminum.
And there is aluminum.
For us, this is all we see now.
We don't see any
of this anymore.
We only see atoms and electrons
because those are the building
blocks, right?
Those are the building blocks.
And the thing is
that, if we write down
all the orbitals of an aluminum
atom, there's the core,
there's a shell,
there's another shell,
there's these ones out
here, way out here, right,
in the case of aluminum,
three of them that are really,
really, kind of weakly bonded.
Right?
They're way out there.
They're loose.
They have the ability
to come off easily.
We talked about this in the
context of other properties,
right?
You know, the polarizability,
the electronegativity, right?
All of this feeds in.
Everything is determined by
where these electrons are.
And then also, as I mentioned,
by how the atom's arranged.
That comes next week.
But if they're really,
really kind of almost free,
then you can kind of
picture it like this.
Let's dial it back to sodium.
And you can kind of picture a
metal as truly free electrons,
right.
They are truly free.
They're not in-- they're
in the middle of that band
and they've got all this freedom
because the states are free
all around them, and
they're basically not really
that attached to any
one atom or another.
And this is really the
picture of the metallic bond.
So let's use--
let's go over here.
They're so free when these atoms
come together with those very,
very loosely bound
outer electrons,
those electrons are so free
we actually call it a sea.
We call it the electron sea.
It's a simplified way
to think about it,
but it's a good
picture to start with.
So in metals, you've
got this electron sea.
Electron sea, we'll
call it a model
because it's a way of thinking.
And in this model, you've got
a positive charge, nuclei,
so you've got
positively charged.
Why?
Because they lost an
electron to the sea.
They've lost it.
Those outer ones have gone.
Well, they're not gone because
there are others around too,
but they're all just
kind of roaming free,
and so you're left with these
positive charges, right?
And these are the cations.
Positively charged
nuclei are cations.
Right.
And they're in a
sea of electrons
and so this is because the
valence electrons is not
tightly bound.
This is what I've been saying,
but this is why you get it.
Cations, so positive
charge nuclei,
these are cat islands
in a sea of electrons.
So if you think about
a metal in this way,
you understand a lot of
the properties of metals.
This is a very useful way
to think about metals.
And let's go back to
our pictures of bonding.
Let me use this board here.
I'll put it right under here.
And we're going to
finish what we started.
We're going to finish
what we started.
Because, remember, we
talked about covalent.
We talked about ionic.
And then we did all these
intermolecular forces
and the bonding that
comes about from those,
but we didn't do metallic.
So if I do covalent over here,
and I do ionic over here.
Well, OK, covalent
we know, right.
You have a maybe HH.
That's a covalent bond.
That's a non-polar
kind of covalent bond,
caring is sharing.
Or we could have
HF, right, where
it's sort of like, you know,
it's a little less sharing.
But you know, it's
still a covalent bond.
It's a polar
covalent bond, right?
I mean, now in the ionic sense,
you have sodium chloride.
We did that example
where you literally--
chlorine is like give me and
sodium's like OK and that's it.
That's the relationship.
Right.
But see now here, let's
take sodium and let's
just put a bunch of them around.
Well, but see, if I've
got an electron sea,
then my electrons are simply
wandering around in the sea.
So every ion has this kind of
ocean of electrons around it.
They're not attached.
It would be like if you say,
how are you going to parent?
Well, I'm going to parent
them until, you know,
you can only go into
the backyard and play.
That's It, right?
You are confined to
be in the backyard.
And now you say, well, OK,
but now if I'm a proton
and I'm parenting an electron,
I say, you know what?
You can be in any yard.
It doesn't matter.
Don't even come home.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't care.
Another kid's going to come
into my backyard at some point,
so it's all good.
That is the relationship of
a metal inside of a metal.
Maybe here it's like the
two houses switch kids.
I don't know what's going on.
No.
One of them just took the kid.
[LAUGHTER]
But anyway.
All right.
I'm going too far.
But here's the thing.
I want to give you that
sense that they're just
roaming around in a sea.
They're roaming around.
Now, here's the point.
I've got a sea of electrons--
oh.
Oh, huh, we can
finish our table.
I'm going to finish that table.
We started the table.
Let's finish the table.
Because now, if I have
metallic, all right,
and I have this kind
of, you know, this kind
of set up here, right.
That's the picture.
That's the model.
And here I have cation--
remember our table-- slash
delocalize, delocalize
electrons.
And the bonding strength
for this table in kilojoules
per mole is 75 to 1,000.
It's a big range.
We'll talk about that.
And there is an example, iron.
We finished our table.
That's it.
That's the last entry.
Now, remember, this
part of the table
was the basis of attraction.
Remember that?
And we filled this out for
all the other types of bonds,
the basis of attraction.
I want to point out that every
single basis we have covered
involves the same
thing, understanding
what electrons are doing.
What is the
electronic structure?
That's the fundamental
principle of this class, right?
That's the key component,
the key ingredient,
that's in all of our recipes.
What are those electrons doing?
That leads us to every single
one of those kinds of bonds,
including metallic.
All right.
So now, you can imagine how this
controls the properties, right?
But first you say, well,
if I had a group one
metal, if I had a group one
metal, then I've got two--
I've got one,
right, like sodium.
But if I go over
to magnesium, you
can see that I've got a
higher charge because both
of those electrons are likely
to leave and wander around
in this sea of electrons.
So that would be what
magnesium looks like in terms
of this electron sea model.
But the thing is that
this sea, this picture,
is what helps us understand
the properties of metals
and that's what I
want to talk about.
That's what I want
to talk about.
And these are some of
the properties, right?
You can go through
metals and there's
a whole range of
properties, but these
are some of the ones that
are pretty consistent.
They are reflective.
They're shiny.
There are literally
settings in like photo apps.
Metallic, make it look metallic.
Right?
Because metals are shiny.
They have luster.
Why?
They have high
electrical conductivity.
That's the thing we've
talked about a lot already.
They have a high
thermal conductivity.
I'll mention that.
High heat capacity.
They're malleable and ductile.
All of these and many
more properties of metals
can be explained from this one
simple picture of the electron
sea.
This one simple picture.
OK.
So let's start.
So if I think about--
let's look at these
top three, OK?
So I'll start, why
is a metal shiny?
Why is a metal shiny?
Well, it goes back
to the thing we've
been talking about
all along, you
know, or certainly in
a lot of parts, right?
The bohr model, and atoms,
and electrons getting excited.
The semiconductors
and LEDs, right?
It has to do with how photons
interact with the material.
But see, now I've
got these electrons
that are sitting out
there at any energy
level ready for the photon.
There's no gap.
Right?
So I've got electrons
sitting around in the sea
and they're ready for anything,
any kind of energy that
hits them, well, they've
got room to be excited.
Right?
They've got room to be excited.
And it's that, combined
with other things,
but it's that, that
is a big part of why
metals have their shininess.
Those electrons can be
excited in almost any way,
right, because there's an
infinite number of states
right there.
There's no gap.
Right?
So the way they can respond
to energy from photons
is extremely diverse.
And you can imagine,
if I'm a photon
and I excite an
electron, it doesn't
matter what the wavelength is.
That electron can fall back
down and re-emit the same energy
photon.
OK.
So that's luster either way.
But now you know and you
really should do this.
And look at.
I just said, you
know, you have this.
I've got electrons.
I shine photons on these.
They might come up
and go back down.
There's all this room here
for electrons to be excited.
There's no gap.
Whereas in diamond, in diamond
I've got this huge gap, right?
Remember, diamond
is an insulator.
Diamond has a gap of 5.5
electron volts, roughly.
Now you know why
diamonds are transparent.
It's of course, the electrons.
Of course.
Because if I shine
photons on this,
and those photons
are indivisible,
you know that even if I go all
the way up to purple photons,
they're not that high.
So any time I try to--
so I'm shining
photons on my diamond
and those electrons are
like, can I go here?
No.
Can I go here?
You have to shine a very
high energy photon to excite
an electron in diamond.
That's why it's
transparent, right?
That's the reason.
When you go to the
store to buy diamonds,
you should ask them
about the electrons.
That's what's
making it all work.
That's what explains
the properties.
But back to metals.
Now, OK, so that's luster.
What about electrical
conductivity?
Well, it's the same thing.
It comes from the sea.
If I take a wire of
copper and I look
at this as a sea of electrons,
so I'm not drawing the ions,
they're in there.
I'm just drawing
the fact that I've
got this sort of
ocean of electrons
that are fairly free, right?
Well, what is happening
when I try to move them,
it is with some kind of
electromagnetic force, right?
There's some kind of force.
And what that means is
that I have a charge
that this doesn't like.
So like it's a repulsive
charge over here.
It's going to push one of
these into the other one.
But then that's going to feel--
that's going to feel--
a force is going to move
and then that's going
to push this one,
and that's going to push
that one, and so forth.
That's how electricity
works, right?
So the actual movement
of the electrons
could be slow in the material,
but the current, right, you
can push a lot of current
through because these ones
over here feel pretty quickly
the forces you applied over
there.
But they only feel
it, they only feel it
if you can get this freedom.
If those electrons
are not free, they're
going to feel this
repulsion there and be like,
you know what?
I'm stuck in my state.
I'm stuck in this
full valence band.
I got nowhere to go.
Sorry.
You know, put your energy into
the atom or something else.
I don't know, but
I'm not moving.
Ah, but if it's a sea,
then you can push them
and they can push each other.
Right?
That's the same thing.
It's a conceptual
picture, but it's
the same thing as almost an
infinite number of free states.
That's what that means, right?
That's what that means.
Now, if you've got
copper, we see copper
now as something like argon
with those d electrons filled,
3d 10, and an s electron here.
And so if it's a
copper wire, those d
electrons it's all
filled up in there
and they act as a
way of shielding,
it's a beautiful
shielding, so that this
is even more free and less
interested in staying around.
So copper's such
a great conductor
and that whole column is such
a great conductor and this is,
by the way--
oh, such a good thing
to do on a Friday night.
I'm so glad it's Friday.
Look at this, ptable.com.
Ha.
You could spend hours on this.
I do spend hours on this.
[LAUGHTER]
Property.
Electrical conductivity And
then it shows you dark green
is high--
dark green is high-- and
then no coloring is low.
And then you can
just click around.
You just click around.
I could do it now, but
I would never leave.
But you go there and you can
click on different properties
and see the trends in
the periodic table,
and it's a beautiful thing.
And you now can understand
them because of the ways
in which electrons behave.
So you can see-- look at this.
There's copper, right?
So there's copper,
and below that, we've
got silver and gold.
And this is a really
high set of elements.
The electrical conductivity
in these three elements
is super high, and this is why.
Because in each case, you're
going down but you're filling
the d's.
Oh, and then you're
even filling f's.
Screening.
Further away.
Really free s-electrons.
High conductivity.
Electron sea, right?
Very easy to push them around.
Now.
OK.
This also goes back to this
picture, because, remember,
I snuck it in because
it was on the graph,
and I didn't take it out.
But there was a
picture of silicon,
where I showed
silicon increasing
its intrinsic carrier
concentration with temperature,
and on top of that was a metal.
I think was tungsten.
Now if you draw the
metal, it would be way up.
It would be way up right
here because this is higher,
but it went this way.
But now you know why.
It's totally different.
The reason is totally different
than why this changes,
but you can understand it
for the same root, which is
the behavior of the electrons.
So, in a metal, in
a semiconductor,
this temperature dependence--
here, I've taken the
temperature dependence away
because I've doped it.
But here, that's the
thermal activation
into a place of freedom,
into a place where they can
be free in the conduction band.
Here, they're
already totally free.
So what's happening?
Well, when I increase
the temperature,
I'm increasing the vibrations.
You can imagine if these
electrons are trying
to do their thing, and
they're in a sea of electrons,
the last thing I want to
do if I'm moving along
is to see some big
ion moving around.
And if it moves more, then it's
going to make me more upset
and get in my way.
That's temperature.
That's why this goes
down and not up.
For metals, the more
thermal energy you put in,
the more those ions--
those positive charges--
they're positive--
are going to interfere with
the electrons being free.
Oh, we are understanding things.
We understood why these have--
now, you might say, why
are these different?
That's complicated.
Relativity.
Not part of this class.
But if you want to understand
why these are different from
a-- they're all really high--
why are they different, it goes
beyond the scope of this class,
but it's also a very
interesting story
that has to do with, on the
one hand, relativistic effects.
Now there's another thing,
which is that if I go back
to that table and I did this--
I really did this a lot--
I clicked back and forth between
electrical-- now look up here--
thermal, electrical,
thermal, electrical.
And you can click-- you can
go, mm, mm, mm, mm, and you can
watch the table, and do that
for like five minutes or so.
And what you'll find is
almost nothing changes.
You can't do that with
very many properties.
But for metals, and
those two properties,
they're almost identical.
Again, it goes back to the sea.
It goes back to the sea, because
if you have electrons that
are free in a material, those
can carry not just electricity,
but those can be the
dominant carriers
of thermal energy as well.
And I'm not going to
go into those details.
I just want to mention it.
So this is actually called
the Wiedemann-Franz law,
and it basically says for
metals, that the thermal--
let's see.
OK, I'll just write it here.
Thermal divided by electrical
conductivity for both--
conductivities-- OK, I'm
putting it in parentheses.
It should be thermal
conductivity divided
by electoral conductivity
goes as some constant times
the temperature.
So if you look at that--
so you can look at it by
toggling back and forth
and see how similar these are.
You can also just plot stuff
or find plots of stuff.
Here's one.
Electroconductivity-- this is
at some fixed temperature--
orders of magnitude variation,
tons and tons of
different materials.
This is the Wiedemann-Franz law.
Now you know that law is
simply a result of the fact
that these free electrons
can carry both electrical--
their charge-- as well
as thermal energy,
and that the way
they carry those
are dependent on the material,
dependent on the number
of electrons, and the way
they bond and all that,
but if they carry it
in one way for one,
it carries it the same
way for the other.
And look at all these things.
Now notice here, this word
that's used a lot-- alloy.
Alloy.
These are all-- alloy.
And I mentioned the
word alloy on Wednesday,
because I said if you wanted
to make a good blue LED,
you had gallium nitride
but it was a little too
high in its band gap, so
they alloyed it with other--
then that meant mixing in.
Well, that is done for metals.
That is done for metals
in a very wide range.
Why?
Because the metal
properties that you have,
you may like some of, but
you may not like others.
So like for copper, it's got
this really high conductivity,
but maybe you don't want
it to be so malleable.
What does that mean?
We'll see in 10 minutes.
Malleable, ductile.
So what do you do?
Well, you alloy it.
And so here's an example.
Brass.
Well, we know brass,
but now you know brass.
Now you really know brass.
You didn't know brass.
You don't know
anyone or anything
until you see it as
an atom and electrons.
That is how you know someone.
Copper?
With zinc substituted
in a two-to-one ratio--
copper to zinc--
the connectivity drops.
Those electrons are not as free,
but they're still pretty free.
Maybe they're a little more
tied up in the bonding,
and maybe what you've
done by alloying
has changed its
mechanical properties,
because I kind of want
something copper-like
but I wanted to have different
mechanical properties,
so I alloyed it.
And this is really how we
think about materials design.
I need something
to have, let's say,
a certain set of properties.
Well, I don't have
them all here,
and I don't have them
all here, but how can I
use a combination?
How can I use a combination
to get what I want?
Bronze is copper with tin--
four-to-one ratio
of copper and tin.
The conductivity drop even more.
It's not so simple.
It's not so simple as,
oh, if it's four-to-one,
then maybe it's like 20%.
No, because it has
to do with what
happens to the freedom
of these electrons.
That's what it has to do with,
and that's more complicated.
But maybe I've changed the
properties in another way
that I really like.
Well, those are substitutional.
Substitutional alloys means
I took one of the coppers out
and I replaced it
with something else.
Here's brass with zinc in there.
You can also have
interstitial alloys,
and interstitial alloys--
so if we-- we'll be coming
back to this when we talk about
crystals next week--
but alloys-- actually when
we talk about defects.
So you can have substitutional--
substitutional--
and you can have interstitial.
This is just a preview.
Interstitial.
We're not going to
be testing on this
or thinking about
this much until we
get to actually putting
these things in to a crystal
later as defects.
But right now, I just want
to make sure you see them
for the first time.
Substitution, interstitial.
Why would you want
one or the other?
Well, it depends
on what properties
you're trying to change.
In this case, I
really like iron.
It's really cheap.
It's a cool material, but
I need it to be stronger.
And that's called steel.
And if you just put a little bit
of carbon-- really, not much,
like a percent by weight--
it can dramatically change the
mechanical properties of iron.
You can make it a much
stronger material.
There is a massive, massive
range of properties.
And part of why
metals are so tunable
is because of the electron sea.
I just came across
this article actually,
and I thought I'd show you.
This was just
literally yesterday.
Was that yesterday?
I thought it was an
interesting example.
Car Wars: Steel
Getting Stronger,
Lighter to Curb Aluminum Rise.
Well, see the thing is that as
you want cars to be lighter--
think fuel efficiency, or
range, if it's electric--
you've got to use
lighter metals.
And aluminum is lighter, but
aluminum is more than twice
as much a steel.
It's a lot lighter though.
So there's a lot of
interest in making steel--
that's just iron with
carbon interstitial--
and making steel stronger.
And you can see, "Newest alloy."
That's what caught my attention.
Newest alloy.
They've come up with
something to add
to iron to make its
mechanical properties really,
really good at a
very, very thin layer
because they need steel to
be even stronger in a much
thinner layer.
Otherwise, it's too heavy.
And you've got to make it
really thin and really strong.
Those are going to be alloys.
OK.
Back to our property list.
Now, malleability and ductility.
Why are metals
malleable and ductile?
Well, I thought this was
a good place for a video
because I really like it.
I think this is a really simple
explanation of malleability
and ductility as it relates
to the electron sea.
So let's watch this.
This looks like a minute long.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE] shatters.
And this is because the
applied force pushes light ions
close together.
They violently repel each other,
breaking the crystal apart.
That's an ionic crystal.
- In contrast, if you hit
a metal with a hammer,
it doesn't break.
It just dents.
Metals are able to
deform form in response
to an applied force.
The mobile sea of electrons
shields the cations
from each other, preventing
violent repulsion
and allowing the
metal to change shape.
The most malleable
metal is gold.
A similar property to the
malleability of metals
is their ability to be
pulled into long thin wires.
We call this ductility.
Ionic compounds are not ductile
for the same reason they
are not malleable in general.
If an ionic compound is
forced into a long cylinder,
it breaks apart because of
the repulsion of like ions.
In contrast, a
metal can be pulled
into a long cylindrical
shape because the cations can
line up, shielded
from each other,
as the fluid-like like sea of
electrons flows around them.
That's my favorite part.
- The most ductile metal--
[END PLAYBACK]
Fluid-like sea.
Oh.
The most ductile metal.
What is it?
We may never know.
We may-- it's platinum.
But see, now, OK.
OK.
Now that's a--
I just gave it away.
OK.
Ductile, malleable,
sea of electrons.
Sea of electrons.
Because did you see
them flowing around?
You're moving the atom--
that was like a dance thing.
That can be like
a new dance move
that you try out tonight, the
sea of electrons dance move.
I'm just saying.
I'm not going to do it again.
But the sea of electrons is
able to move around the ions
as they're distorting
because the metal bond is not
so directional.
The metal bond is
not so directional.
Because think about it.
What is holding
the metal together?
It's these interactions
between the house and the kids
that are roaming
all over the place.
Is the kid over
there or over there?
It doesn't matter.
Just give me a little
bit of negative charge
so I can feel an attraction.
That's the metal--
that's why it is so able
to deform in the way it does.
Because those atoms
are moving around,
and the electrons are just kind
of there as this happy sea,
and the bonding remains.
It doesn't break.
That's the key.
Otherwise, this thing
would just crack.
So wire-pulling--
check this one out.
You can take a 10-centimeter
by one-centimeter platinum rod,
and you can spin that into
a wire, and this is done--
this is a very thin
case for effect.
But you can make a
0.0006-millimeter diameter
wire, and you get 2,777
kilometers of wire.
Now that's because of ductility.
The only reason I
can get from point A
to point B there is because
I'm not breaking this apart,
and that's how thin I can get--
27-millimeter diameter
when I pull it.
And I thought that was a
really good example of why
this matters, because
maybe you've noticed,
but wires are really
important to us.
We use them a lot.
And so, I you just saw in
a cartoon with electrons.
Here is a cartoon that I
thought was interesting that
shows a wire-pulling setup.
So, now this is--
Die, reducing the diameter.
That's a die.
Further reduction can take
place using extra dies.
The drawn wire is
finally wound on a spool.
This transformation
elongates the wire.
One meter of 5.5-millimeter wire
rod can be drawn to 30 meters
with one millimeter diameter
or 484 meters with 0.25
millimeters diameter.
OK.
Now, that is a cartoon, and
I think it's always good.
When you see cartoons
like this, you don't know.
Go look up what
the real deal is.
What does it really
look like to draw wires?
And I found it pretty cool.
So this is an actual
wire-drawing plant,
and this is what it looks like.
Now, there's no audio
here, but I just
wanted to show
you the magnitude.
Those are huge towers
that are melting metals
to give you this first rod,
and then it goes through one
after the other.
And look at it being pulled--
being pulled in
at some diameter,
and it comes out in
a different diameter.
But I wanted to show you
the scope and size of this.
This is just one of them.
There's a person, and so
you get a sense of the size,
and then you can
also see something--
when you go visit
these factories,
and I have these
factories, there's
always a lot of this happening.
Why?
Things are getting really hot.
When you're spinning things like
a wire at a very high velocity,
things heat up, so you get
water all over the place.
So there's water being
sprayed in factories
all over the place, because
you've got to keep stuff cool,
or there's water baths that
you run these things through.
And then you've got
to think about, well,
does this thing
interact with water?
How does the water play a role?
It all comes down
to the electrons.
And once they've actually
drawn the wire out
over this huge factory,
they can actually
weave it back together.
So I found this.
This is the same factory.
Now these things here
are doing the opposite.
So these are huge drums,
about the size of a person,
and each of these got
a wire that was drawn.
And now, again, because
of the ductility,
you can also move the
wires, play with the wires,
and you can weave them together.
You can weave them
right back together
into a thread that looks
like that, which we all have
seen I think many, many times.
All of this processing, all
of this manufacturability,
has to do with the electron sea.
That's why we have wires
OK.
Now, a couple more small points.
So we're going to go
back to this picture
because this is how we started.
And this is the 1-D--
remember that 1-D model that we
used to introduce band theory--
and I want to go back to this,
because what you can see is
that if I think about this
as bonding and anti-bonding
orbitals all kind
of mixed in here,
then you can also get a sense,
just like in the dimers that we
make--
N2, O2, remember NO?
Bond order.
It counts how many electrons
are in an anti-bonding orbital.
Just because it's in
an anti-bonding orbital
doesn't mean it's not
there in the system.
It's the same with
these metal bands.
Some of them may be
good for bonding.
Some of them may not.
But just like in the
dimers, the bond order
is related to the
strength of that bond.
Remember?
And in NO, it's like a
bond order of 2 and 1/2,
and then if I took an electron
out, it actually got stronger.
The bonding got stronger.
It's the same thing.
You can think about this
the same way in metals.
You have a band.
Some of these orbitals are not
going to be bonding orbitals,
and some of them are going to
be much more about the bonding.
And so that's going to relate
to things like boiling point.
Metals have boiling points too.
So if you look now, go
back to the periodic table,
remember the highest electrical
connectivity was here.
Well, that had to do with that
right there, with the position,
with the filling of
the orbitals to give me
the freest electron
I can imagine,
after those d-orbitals
are filled, that s.
But if I'm thinking
about whether I filled
anti-bondings orbitals
or not, because now I'm
thinking about the
strength of the bonds,
you see a different trend,
and you see something
that you would expect.
First of all, you see
a huge variability,
but you see that the
ones that are strongest--
the highest boiling points--
are going to be the ones
where you fill that band--
those bands-- roughly halfway.
And this is also why,
in a metallic bond,
in a metallic bond, you've
got this enormous range.
So you've got-- it's
the weakest for elements
with near-empty,
near empty, valence
subshells, valence
subshells, and I
would say, like OK,
caesium is an example,
or near-full, like, for
example, in mercury.
Now mercury is actually
a liquid at room
temperature because of this.
There it is.
Why?
Because I-- remember
the beryllium dimer.
I filled all these
electrons in there,
and they're causing this really
weak bonding, this really weak
bonding, because I
had to put all of them
into the anti-bonding orbitals.
I couldn't do this trick
that right over here, right
one column next
to it, these guys
can have tricks, where they--
now this is bonding strength.
This is not electroconductivity.
But here, they're filling the
d, and then the s is free.
Not here.
Here they're all filled,
bonding and anti-bonding.
No tricks.
Now, if you look at the
melting temperature-- that's
one of the strongest
elements would be tungsten.
The strongest would be
example tungsten, where
you've got a range of melting--
the melting point of tungsten--
and this is not the same
as the boiling point--
the melting point of
tungsten is 3,680 degrees C.
That's a liquid at
room temperature.
And the melting point
of cesium is 28 degrees
C. Look at that range.
And it all has to do with
how these electrons are
filling the metallic bands.
And more than that, because
it also has to do with the way
the atoms come together,
and that is going
to be the topic of next week.
Now that would have
been a perfect line
to end on because I said
the words, "next week."
I just want to make
one more point.
I can't stop because
there is one more
thing I want to show very
quickly in one minute.
And that is-- going
back to this picture,
if you're thinking
about filling,
and I've got like my 3s--
remember, I've got like my 3s--
and let's put 2p here
and then 3s and 3p.
Now remember, for metals, for
a lot of these metals, what
ends up happening is what I
showed you before on Wednesday,
which is that you get
actually an overlap of this,
so you get a band that
would be the 3s/3p band.
Sodium, magnesium,
aluminum-- these
all come together like
this to form a single band.
Now remember, I don't need
you to know how to do this.
We would tell you if
it does this or not.
And we talked about that.
I'm not going to ask you to
know how these come together,
do they form a
continuous band or not?
But in this case,
they do, for that row.
And so you know.
I've got eight electrons,
eight-electron capacity
in that band per atom.
That's the capacity of the band.
So now I want to talk about,
how is this band filled?
Well, for sodium, I'm
going to fill it 1/8th,
because it's got just
one electron that it's
putting into that band.
And for magnesium, I'm going
to fill it with two electrons.
And aluminum would be three.
And so on.
So it goes back to the
same picture as before.
We're filling the
bands, but now we've
got 10 to the 23rd
and 24th atoms,
and so we think about
filling the bands
as what's the occupancy per
atom you can put in there?
And so I could tell you
if I had a mole of sodium,
how many electrons I
have in this band, right?
It's a mole.
And how did you fill it?
And that ties into what
I just talked about,
which is how that relates
to bonding strength.
OK.
Now we can stop.
On Monday, we will start
talking about crystals.
Have a very good weekend.